the thing about war is it only works as
both sides believe they're the good guys
the truth is were not so different we
fight to get back what was once ours
but in the end and this is the end it's
just a city you'll get used to watching
them fall microsites for us we need to
figure out our next vote so no next move
and there is no we
what is that we're not here to eat but
those pork on a shrimp oh this guy's got
pork god you're weird I'm not looking
for super taste that doesn't matter
can't fight these people
not even with whatever it is your hand
can do it's cheap it's not there hunting
our friends our families and I'm not
going to stop there
[Music]
more death is coming the only thing
keepin Manhattan from Kremlin to a pile
of dust the four of you the wars are New
York it's over
nor jack
[Music]
I fear reports
I can see you've formed a kind of pond
I promise he was temporary
Tigra they will disappoint you
Jessica like it or not
you belong out there together
glad we found each other I'm not hugging
you spend long week
happy Comicon week continues they
finally dropped the new defenders
trailer they also aired a Punisher
trailer but they didn't allow that to be
posted online so I'll break that down in
this video first and then I'll talk
about the defenders footage because
Punisher in my mind was actually the
more exciting thing but they might wait
to release it till a little bit later in
the year so I will say new round of the
Marvel giveaway it starts now all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video
they also screened the first episode so
I'll do a non-spoilery review of that
tomorrow morning before the Justice
League panel so here we go Frank starts
out teaching his daughter how to play
guitar in a flashback then they go back
to him in prison in a different
flashback then there's a shot of him
closer to present day chasing down two
dudes on a motorcycle he guns them down
with the shotgun then runs them over
with the motorcycle then you cut to
Juarez Mexico a bunch of drug dealers
are celebrating without knowing that the
Punisher is watching them through the
scope on his rifle he takes aim guns
them down then the camera slowly backs
away from the side of the gun and you
see that he's miles and miles away using
a sniper rifle just like he was at the
end of daredevil season 2 so then you
cut to JFK Airport this is a bit of a
funny Punisher takedown moment you're in
JFK Airport in the bathroom there's
someone named Mickey on the phone
talking about a party in a really casual
manner then all of a sudden Punisher in
full comic book costume busts into his
bathroom stall he flips his [ __ ] then
starts beating the crap out of him it
jumps to a couple other dudes that are
in the bathroom listening from other
stalls to all this commotion they think
that two dudes are having sex in the
bathroom stall next to them but it's
really just the Punisher beating the
[ __ ] out of this drug dealer you find
out that he's actually the kingpin of
the drug cartel that he's been
dismantling in the rest of this clip so
he killed a bunch of them in Juarez
Mexico he killed some of them on the
bike with the shotgun now he's taking
out the kingpin and then all of a sudden
the bathroom stall gets really quiet
Punisher walks out casually and just
leaves the bathroom and then it cuts to
black Jon Bernthal did a whole bunch of
interviews he is a total champ just
listen to the dedication that he has to
this character in the
the book community the act of reading a
comic book
it requires so much of the audience's
imagination so these characters they
really exist so much in the audience's
imaginations and there's a sense of
ownership there and I want to do right
by it I want to honor the iterations
that have come before me so now moving
on to the defenders footage the trailer
doesn't offer too many more clues about
what hold the hand is digging in the
middle of New York City in the
mysterious pit that we saw during
daredevil season 2 you get all those
funny interactions that the characters
have in Alexandra's character who has a
lot of voice over talking to the
electric character most of the voiceover
she has is when she's talking to Elektra
trying to brainwash her against the rest
of the group they'll let you down like
they reveal the fact that Elektra has
amnesia after she's brought back from
the dead she's being used by Alexandra's
hand character to be turned into a
weapon so that's why you see her
fighting daredevil and all the other
defenders in that hallways scene in the
trailer like why does she hate them all
of a sudden I thought she loved Matt the
actress was joking around like how much
of Elektra remains after her
resurrection how much of her is still
inside there so obviously it sounds like
she's going to switch sides back and
she'll be just as chaotic as she's ever
been that sort of her thing is that she
just sort of blows wherever the wind
takes her but I love Luke Aegis reacting
to a lot of this craziness you know I'm
not hugging you it looks like iron fist
has fixed his Chi at least a little bit
he's a little bit more powerful and I
just love the way that they play with
color in the trailer too so they
definitely went above and beyond you can
tell they really spent the extra money
because it's only eight episodes instead
of 13 but let me know what you guys
think about this I think it's fantastic
I really hope they dropped that Punisher
trailer sometime soon too maybe that's
the secret post-credit scene they said
is going to be at the end of this
because they did reveal defenders would
have a post-credits scene Marvel movie
style at the end of the finale in the
other really big news speaking of Danny
ran they confirmed iron fist season 2 is
going to happen misty Knight will
crossover so if you're really hoping for
some misty night iron fist action
they're sort of setting that up so they
didn't really reveal anything about the
villains of Punisher season 1 other than
it's going to be jigsaw like jigsaw is a
big part of the series he's being played
by Ben Barnes you probably saw him on
West
old or some other series he's going to
be fantastic he'll still look like
pretty boy benbarnes at the beginning of
the series presumably over the course of
the series Punisher is going to mow him
down just like he did in the comic book
and that's when he'll get that messed up
face starting to look like jigsaw but
like I said I'll try to get out that
non-spoilery defenders episode 1 review
tomorrow morning before the Justice
League panel otherwise my next video
will be a Justice League trailer video
they are bringing Aquaman and yes I know
you're all asking about Ben Affleck
leaving the role of Batman all these
rumors that we're flying around this
morning I'll address that during that
Justice League video so no worries so
get hype Marvel trailers infinity war
Thor Ragnarok all kinds of stuff
happening Saturday night what you wait
for everything you can click here for a
brand new game of Thrones trailer and
you can click here to rewatch that
stanley punisher trailer thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight
you